سيد
تم كيف كيف ترى هذا الاستهداف الجديد
والذي يضاف الى سلسله الاستهدافات
للصحفيين في غزه وقد بلغ عددهم منذ بدايه
الحرب
109 شهداء من الصحفيين استهدفوا مباشره في
هذه
الحرب الامر صادم جدا وهو يسبب الغضب
دعوني اقل اولا بانني اقدم تعازيه الحاره
لوائل الدحدوح ولكم جميعا فهذا لابد بانه
اخبار صادمه لكم ان نطاق القتل بين
الصحفيين في غزه هو امر غير مسبوق في اي
صراع شهدناه ومن الصعب
ان لا نقول ان هذا
الاستهداف معمد اذا فهو متعمد وهذه قصه
مروعه وهي تجسد العناء والالم في غزه
ويمكن ان امل فقط من خلال هذه المنصه ان
اتحدث ل للعالم كله عن العناء للصحفيين
واملوا ان يزيد هذا الضغوط على المعنيين
لوقف هذا القتل تقول ان هذا الاستهداف
متعمد
لماذا تستهدف اسرائيل بشكل متعمد الصحفيين
منذ بدايه هذه
الحرب لا يمكنني ان اتحدث باسم اسرائيل
وليس لدي معلومات بالنسبه للعمليه
العسكريه التي يقومون بها باستثناء
الشهادات التي سمعتها من كثير من الصحفيين
في غزه بانهم يستهدفون وايضا من حيث عدد
الناس الذين قتلوا هذا لا يفسر الا بتلك
الطريقه اذا فال الاستنتاج الذي لدي هو ان
هذه محاوله لكي يكون هناك الصرف لانتباه
العالم عن غزه
و وعن ما تقوم باسرائيل نحن نعلم انهم لم
يسمحوا لصحفيين الوليين ان يعبروا الى غزه
اذا فال الشهاده الوحيده التي هي متوفره
لدينا تاتي من الصحفيين في غزه ومنهم 10%
قد فقدوا ارواحهم
وهذا امر غير مسبوق فهناك 10% كما قلنا قد
فقدوا ارواحهم من الصحفيين هل يمكن لهذه
الاستهدافات المتعمده ان تبقى من دون
محاسبه سيد
تم املي من المجتمع الدولي ومؤسسته ان
يحمل اسرائيل المسؤوليه عن هذه الهجمات
ادعو الحكومه الاسرائيليه الان لكي تقوم
باحترام القانون الدولي وان تقدم
الادله بانه ليس هناك قتل للصحفيين كما
كان الحال هو اصلا الان وضمان ان لا يكون
هناك استهداف للصحفيين املي للمحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه ان تقوم بالتحقيق في بعض
هذه القضايا الظروف في غزه لا تسمح
بالقيام بعمليه تحقيق ولكن هذا الامر يجب
القيام به وامل من المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه ومن السيد خان بالتحديد والذي ذهب
الى غزه والتقى صحفيين وقال لهم انه مستعد
للقيام باجراء عمليه تحقيق خاصه
بجرائم قتل الصحفيين وامل لهذا الامر ان
يتم وان يكون هناك وازع للقيام بهذه
العمليه بشكل مفصل وسريع جدا جدا انتم
كمؤسسات معنيه بالصحفيين وحقوق الصحفيين
وحريه
عملهم ما هو دوركم على هذا
الصعيد لا انكر بان الوضع صعب جدا فا
ادخال او التغطيه هي صعبه جدا الان واقول
ان قابه الصحفيين الفلسطينيين
وهي قدمت لها الاموال لكي تقوم
بالعمل ولكي تقوم بواجباتها الضروريه كما
انها هي جزء لا يتجزا من الاتحاد الدولي
للصحفيين لذلك نود ان نقدم لهم الخيم
وكل المستلزمات لهم وخاصه انهم فقدوا كل
ممتلكاتهم وامتعت لذلك نامل ان يكون هنا
هناك سبيل لادخال المساعدات لهم
وللمدينة
سالتك عن
الدور المنوط بكم في مساله محاسبه اسرائيل
وتقديمها
للمحاكم الدوليه نتيجه استهدافها المتعمد
للصحفيين الصوت
متقطع
زميلكم زميلتكم شيرين ابو عاقله قتلت في
شهر مايو من العام الماضي ونحن بالتالي
قمنا بحث المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه ان
تعتني بهذه القضيه وان يكون هناك ضغط
للقيام بعمليه التحقيق وبسرعه اذا فهناك
طيف واسع من الشكاوى يجب ان تقدم للمحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه ونحن نعمل مع نقابه
الصحفيين
الفلسطينيين لذلك نحاول ان نقدم كل الادله
وكل ما يلزم للقيام برفع دعوه قضائيه هل
تلاحظون ان اسرائيل لا تلقي بالا
لكل مواقف المؤسسات الدوليه المعنيه
بالصحافه
والصحفيين وهي
تستهتر بهم بشكل
عملي
من الواضح بان هناك سياسيين في
اسرائيل يصدرون بالقانون الدولي والقواعد
الدوليه لكن املي هو ان من هم حريصون في
اسرائيل على
سمعتهم بانهم سوف يقومون بتحويل التيار ضد
اولئك الذين يصنعون الحرب بهذه الطريقه
ربما هذا هو اقصى امل لدينا هذه الحرب ما
زالت قائمه واملنا ان يكون هناك اناس
لديهم
اراده ان يكون هناك تحويل لما يجري الان
عن مساره والعمل بطريقه افضل كيف كيف يمكن
وضع حد الان لان الحرب ما زالت مستمره اذا
كانت المحاسبه
والشكاوى الدوليه بعد الحرب لكن الان كيف
يمكن وضع حد لما تقوم به اسرائيل من
استهداف متعمد للصحفيين ماذا يمكن فعل او
ما هو الفعل الذي يمكن القيام به
حاليا اعتقد انه كلما كان هناك المزيد من
الناس يعملون كلما كان الامر افضل يجب ان
نوضح للعالم بان هذا امر مغضب للانسانيه
ويتم القيام بهذه العمليات بطريقه متعمده
انا دائما اتحدث مع الناس الذين هم ليسوا
على اطلاع بان عدد الصحفيين في هذه
المنطقه هو اعلى مما هو تم خلال الاعوام
وخلال التاريخ هناك الكثيرون من الناس
الذين هم مدنيون ويتعرضون للقتل و كل سكان
غزه الان امامهم ماساه وهم يقومون بالصبر
ولكن الصحفيين عانوا بشكل خاص وعلينا ان
نوضح هذا الامر جليا في كل منتد يمكننا
القيام بذلك من خلاله ان كان لي سبيل لوقف
هذه الحرب فسوف اقوم بوقف هذه الحرب
ولكنني لا امتلك هذه الصلاحيات اذا يجب
لفت انتباه العالم لهذه الماساه ولوقف هذه
الحرب وهذا هو السبيل الوحيد المتاح
امامنا الان هل يجري التواصل مع مؤسسات في
الدول التي تدعم مؤسسات
صحفيه في الدول التي تدعم اسرائيل في
حربها على غزه هل هناك تواصل من قبلكم مع
تلك
المؤسسات لدينا زملاء لنا في الولايات
المتحده حده وفي مؤسستين كلتاهما
تدعي دعتا الى وقف هذه الماساه ضد
الصحفيين وهم ايضا يناشدون حكوماتهم
للتصرف والتحرك هذه الامور ما زالت جاريه
ولكن في الولايات المتحده الراي الان
يتحول والناس اصبحوا
يستيقظون بشان هذه الجرائم وينتبه لها
اكثر
واكثر عدم محاسبه
اسرائيل على استهداف الصحفيين ايه رساله
ترسل من خلال ذلك الى المؤسسات الصحفيه
والى الصحفيين عبر العالم الذين يقومون
بعملهم في مناطق الحروب بشكل
خاص
نعم نحن واجهنا هذه المشكله لاعوام طويله
والدول والدول المارقه والاشخاص
الاثرياء يقومون باستهداف الصحفيين لمنعهم
من التغطيه وهم يعملون دائما بهذه الطريقه
بافلا تام من العقاب وبدون اي
مسائله ولذلك اعتقد ان ما يجري الان في
هذا الصراع والنطاق الواسع للقتل بين
الصحفيين هذا سوف يمكن كل هذه الانظمه
الاستبداديه بان تقمع حريه التعبير ومنع
الصحفيين من القيام بواجباتهم ما يحدث في
غزه يمكنهم من ذلك لذلك نحن بحاجه الى
القيام بكل ما بوسعنا لكي نلفت الانتباه
لهذه المذبحه وان نتحدث كلنا بصوت واحد
لانهاء هذه الحرب شكرا جزيلا لتم داوسن من
لندن نائب الامين العام للاتحاد الدولي
للصحفيين شكرا لك s